m
le
le myanmar l'un des pays les plus isolés
du monde et l'un des plus pittoresques
avec ses pagodes et ces femmes aux
visages peints pour se protéger des
rayons du soleil
mais malgré la beauté des lieux quelque
chose de tragique se déroule ici alors
que le reste de la planète observant
silence nous sommes dans la région de
raquil la frontière avec le bangladesh
sur des kilomètres et des kilomètres des
maisons de fortune des installations
rudimentaires
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
entassées les unes sur les autres
à l'intérieur de ses camps une bataille
quotidienne pour demeurer en vie
nab et sa famille vivent dans la baraque
numéro 134 depuis deux ans ils n'ont
accès ni à l'eau potable ni à de la
nourriture de qualité ni à des
médicaments notre camp est à peine mieux
qu'une prison nous n'avons aucune
liberté on contrôler nos allées et
venues et on suffoque dans nos abris
communauté musulmane bangladesh pendant
des décennies ils ont vécu de façon
pacifique côte à côte avec leurs voisins
bouddhiste mais la situation a changé en
à la suite d'un viol une vague de
violence sans précédent a éclaté dans la
région
plus de 200 personnes ont perdu la vie
principalement des musulmans ils 140000
euros in gaz ont été confinés dans ces
camps un nettoyage ethnique selon
l'organisme human rights watch qui comme
bien d'autres ong arrive à peine à
visiter les lieux aujourd'hui depuis
d'héroïne gars sont captifs des guérites
les empêchent de sortir des camps il a
remis se charge de faire régner l'ordre
sur le nouveau territoire nabaa
l'impression pourrir debout pour
survivre il se rend à la mosquée de
fortune que la communauté a érigé la
prière et lancer seul passe-temps depuis
des mois puisque le gouvernement
l'empêchent d'étudier nous n'avons
aucune école ici je ne sais plus quoi
faire
tous mes rêves sont anéantis plus
d'école plus d'emplois mais le besoin le
plus criant et médicales l'an dernier
les bouddhistes ont attaqué il fait fuir
l'organisme médecins sans frontières
sans accès à des soins le jeune frère de
nabaa presque perdu la vie après avoir
attrapé la malaria
je me suis endetté pour lui trouver des
médicaments
encore aujourd'hui je ne sais pas céder
tout à fait rétabli et je n'arrive pas à
rembourser des 3000 qui ya l'équivalent
de 4 dollars canadiens que j'ai emprunté
il y à bien un hôpital à l'intérieur du
camp il y a même des patients mais les
médecins bouddhiste ne le visais jamais
résultat son docteur cet enfant ne
reçoit que des caresses pour guérir sa
fièvre cette femme enceinte reçoit les
encouragements de son ami pour contrôler
ces contractions et s'étonne qu'ils
n'arrivent plus à bouger en raison de
ses maux d'estomac prix pour qu'un
spécialiste arrive à son chevet j'espère
que ce n'est pas un cancer
c'est injuste on viole tous nos droits
pour tenter de fuir la situation
plusieurs jeunes risquent leur vie en
s'échappant vers la thaïlande
mais là aussi ils sont vulnérables sans
papiers ils deviennent des proies
faciles pour les trafiquants d'êtres
humains une crise aussi envenimée par
les moines bouddhistes en l'honneur des
civils à n'utiliser pas le mourant in
gaz ce terme n'existe pas sont des
bangladesh
s'ils ne peuvent pas prouver leur
citoyenneté
ils n'ont rien à faire au myanmar et
nous ne devrions pas les soutenir
financièrement une vision tellement
tranché que pour s'assurer de ne pas se
mettre à dos les bouddhistes lors de la
campagne électorale les prix nobel de la
paix en 110 uci a évité de se prononcer
sur la question
une surprise et une déception pour la
communauté musulmane
puisque la dame de rangoun a été
elle-même en résidence surveillée
pendant 15 ans sous la junte militaire
j'ai l'impression de devenir fou j'en
veux au gouvernement d'avoir volé ma vie
je veux seulement rentrer à la maison
human rights watch accuse des autorités
birmanes de commettre un crime contre
l'humanité au myanmar
alors que d'autres parlent de génocide
des concepts qui n'a pas ne maîtrise pas
et qui sans l'aide de la communauté
internationale ne changeront rien à son
avenir
bloqué derrière des murs et des barrages
policiers